he has been such an incredible friend to
us for many years we just knew that rod
needed work and we had seen the cave
that he had done up on the Mesa and it
was beautiful the project was more about
rod helping Rob than the cave itself he
just said you know it'll take two months
and cost $2000 and we thought okay well
knowing rod it'll take four months and
cost $4,000 but we could probably deal
with that so how long did it take it
took more than two years
listen chills cave was a real difficult
project Liz was in the midst of cancer
treatment serious cancer in hindsight I
should have just stopped the project
until Liz's treatment was farther along
I don't know why I didn't I guess we
were we were hurting for money and I
needed it and we needed income I
remember coming home at one point and
there being a huge hole in the top of
the cave with no plan to close it in and
thinking how far is this going
than the uncertainty of the cave the way
it was developing and not knowing where
it was going all of her you know cancer
fears we're kind of you know went into
the cave it was getting big although
contrary to popular opinion I know when
something's finished when he has a
shovel in his hand he's like a coke
addict live with the piles of coke he
just wants to keep going and going so
Liz would say I have cancer you go
telling me has to stop no that's doubt
but finish what you're doing not make it
any bigger Nikko yeah yeah yet I
couldn't really stop what I was doing I
couldn't adjust it they were getting
more and more anxious about the size you
know people are very scared about having
something that doesn't have blueprints
to it I thought I had convinced him it's
big enough you have to finish it and
then I went up there and he had dug
these classics out in the bedroom area
and they went wow you told me you were
not doing it anymore he suggests these
classes does these classes somehow the
money kept being there when we needed to
pay him and he only worked 20 hours a
week and he was only charging us $15 now
or something like that
there was too much I felt like I was
causing suffering you know while I was
unfolding this project that was you know
it was something I can still feel that
what I'm in was in shells cave I can
still feel the emotional residue
but a sudden it was a beautiful
cathedral light came instead of a
ever-expanding Hall
you know we thought we were doing him a
favor but in the end he was doing us a
favor because he made us this beautiful
beautiful thing
I actually held to the plan that I had
and but that you the original plan was
two months seven twenty years
you know did I say two months
I don't know
the people that I gravitated towards
were called Nazi Punk's Tuesday nights
we're gonna go to the Starwood and we're
gonna get in a fight with whoever and
then the next day we're supposed to go
to school when we were on the rampage
you stood a very good chance of getting
hurt
I remember arriving in Los Angeles in
Hollywood I was just like oh my god this
is gonna be great
but unfortunately the daily routines
became the same as they were in San
Francisco hustling and selling my body
was no longer this terrible awful
victimization it was a means to an end
but I always had this little like I'm
going to make it because I'm still going
to prove her wrong
that evening was more violent than usual
at first glance we saw the Mohawks we
thought well whatever it's just punk
rockers we had gotten it with a club
earlier and we stopped two or three
times simply to get out of the car and
beat somebody up so we're at a
heightened level of aggression
we were across the street from okie dogs
this hamburger stand was the okie dog
across the street directly across trees
where I heard them yell look there they
are again the [ __ ] let's go kill the
[ __ ] as they were chasing me I was
trying to make it out as quickly as I
could I was unaware that there were
several coming from the other direction
and as I get to the end of the alley and
I can see them coming I just like froze
and literally froze I turned and I saw
that the rest of the people that I was
with were kicking somebody on the ground
they started beating punching me first
then kicking me as hard as they could in
order to get me down to the ground
that's how that he was still moving and
I said something to the effect of what's
wrong with you guys you know don't you
know how to put a boot in I remember
looking into that face I remember
looking at that mohawk in those eyes I
kicked him in the forehead and he was
out in those last moments of looking up
and watching these 14 guys with razor
blades glued to the front of their boots
high-fiving each other and they were
congratulating each other they believed
with everything that was within them
that they had accomplished the goal of
killing that kid in the alley who had
never spoken to them had never said
anything to them the words and what I
saw were far more painful throughout my
life than the boots and the blades and
we turned up the music and we drove back
to the suburbs I will tell you was a
long drive it seemed like a very long
drive and I think all of us were sort of
internalizing and processing what had
happened so you know I went through most
of my life thinking that I had killed
this person or at least not knowing
I belong on a ship ab initio Alleluia I
will lead down from Cheryl hey and know
me I'm gonna swirl has been a that song
will be nil hey no sir
has indeed and shocking well as I know
she's been under merkezi women sobbing
horribly notice me I can't Tanaka beer
no esta aqui
Bedell Bell of the Gemini general is a
lizard who you know at the Doudna valve
valve idea and I shall took off good
allies to the inhalation skill that he
kept among hanging
Elaine had father Jamar Nevada alofi you
know happy sub patron and forget that
can govern on the Left madam said that
haddock so not that sir but better
but unless again now listen II can't get
it ready data has to be useful
I'd get us all on that I have to Herrick
unless PG amount with like enough for my
computer I do I need another fish I had
they'll see surely a hassle childhood
or haddock
my opinion is what we learn in school it
is important but much more important is
the atmosphere intellectual atmosphere
of your parents in your home this goes
with you to your end belt of it he is
miracle his music is not only melody
what is inside what is inside how its
felt is full it is intensive
phenomena inspired by her musical heroes
Alice decided on a concert career she
sought out the legendary pianist Arthur
Schnabel but she made the right choice
I wanted to know his opinion about my
level and I played to him and he said
you can't learn with me you can't learn
anything else Alice's life became a
whirlwind of rehearsals and concerts
then one day a particular violinist
caught her eye now Boyd
it recalled the Bootsie he was an
extraordinary violinist and new language
is perfect and everything he knew I was
in love with his knowledge we married in
37 and I talked to my husband now we are
married in the evening when we came home
now we are in the moment when you will
find another woman who is who like more
you can we stay friends it's okay
there are thousands and thousands of
beautiful women in the world
I will be very sad of course but you can
do it
it was 1937 and these were the best of
times for Alice she married the man she
loved she was becoming a musical
celebrity and with the birth of her son
she had it all
my son Rafael he was maybe three years
old not yet
sitting the whole day he loved in this
time was gramophone and suddenly it
comes to an enormous fortissimo
ain't a boy he was three yellow started
to cry dad why do you cry the music is
so beautiful
we here call you sir
how many hours do your volunteers work
today
10 10 hours a day by basically I feel
very comfortable with you guys all my
dad used to be such a segregationist it
is really heartwarming that you guys
have turned him around but it's you guys
that have shown that compassion to my
dad and my dad ain't the guy you used to
be
Prison is a cold place don't give me
room
you know Prison is a cold place but
death is cold no you know you time your
family is thousands and miles away
it's hardest are those who die by
yourself
you know people are passing and people
getting sick every day in prison you
know what you do lock them up in the
room are you get some people that don't
go mind doing it there's a lot of guys
in these yards and yards all over the
country that wouldn't mind doing it you
don't want to do it when I started
hospital I thought it would be about
what I can give to the patient what I
could do for that patient and make them
feel better but when you do what you do
the feeling that you get back from them
you can't even describe it all right so
that easy
it gives you a feeling that inside it
for for once I'm somebody that nobody
thought I could be
be laying on your back so much
I want to start by talking about two
areas of documentary filmmaking that are
key to any successful documentary and
that's access and theme all of your
films achieve such intimate access with
your subject matters which in part is
what makes them so successful
raaah does his work in an area of
northern New Mexico where I have a house
a vacation house and he can only work in
that area because that is where the
material that holds up is both malleable
and structurally sound enough to do the
work that he does I saw one of his caves
over ten years ago when I ran into Liz
and shel who were in that clip I met
them in the town when we first started
going there and they said we're having a
cave dug on our property would you like
to see it and you know that seems sort
of sort of invitation you don't turn
down and that shot that's in this clip
here where you go around the corner and
you the space is revealed was exactly
the spirit experience that I had and I
was completely wowed by it I've never
seen anything like it and I thought at
that time that I would start making a
film but it took me a long time to
figure out actually how to get into the
story part of the film and what would
you say is the theme of the film the
theme of the film you know I think that
cave digger is different than the other
short films in in a very specific way
and that is that it is not about
hardship and it is not about overcoming
adversity and I think that but it's
about something else that's very
important and that is it's about the
outsider and raw is an outsider in so
many ways he has rejected material
things he doesn't pursue material things
even as an artist he doesn't really
pursue recognition so I I was interested
and even in the way that he is
self-taught he's he didn't learn any of
this as you use all of all of
what he knows he's done by following
something instinctual so I was
interested in in celebrating the
outsider because I thought my feeling is
that the outsider represents a sort of
glorious way we can be human you know
Lenny Bruce said you know don't kill the
Freak and I think what he meant but he
was talking about the dissident I think
but that's another kind of outsider that
needs to be celebrated because they
remind us of some possibilities at the
same time I was interested in showing
what the cost of being that person is
and it does cost raw a cost raw
personally it costs him financially he
talks about that a little bit in here it
talked it costs him in his relationships
he has a lot of conflicts with his the
people that have Commission caves and he
has some sense of lack of fulfillment
because of the 13 caves he's done only
three of them he feels her complete
because people run out of money or they
run out of patience so I wanted to show
what the price of being the outsider was
and then through another lens I also
wanted to show the contradiction of
being that person so he's not it's he's
not a saintly guy for for all of his
outside earnest and all of his
willingness to forego the things that we
find so dear
he's a contradiction for instance he
says I don't really do anything to get
any kind of recognition and yet he's
agreed to be in this film which in
itself is a contradiction so there was
some there's something roiling in him
and he talks in the film about how he
doesn't have the kind of respect because
from his patrons because he's not famous
so there and he did talk off camera a
lot about you know Andy Goldsworthy who
is another earth artist who had a very
wonderful film made about him and I
think he was envious of that
so there is that contradiction in that
person so for me I mean if it sounds
like my film isn't I don't have a point
of view about my film that's true I
don't have a point of view about it I
was
one thing I got there was one of the
Twitter things I read said beautiful
film to look at if only it was about
something and I took that as the highest
compliment has the film changed anything
for wrong in terms of his art or his
life
the film has first of all he's never
gotten recognition from the art
community he is an outsider in the
artist world which means that he didn't
come up through the art institutions and
he didn't build his artwork on the back
of any other artist he says he has no
influences so he has just will in may he
will have a big spread in the German
magazine called art which is a glossy
and well-respected art magazine so it
changed it in that way also he did get
some financing from a local person to
complete his project that he's doing
entirely by himself so yes right Jason
facing fear how did you come upon this
incredible story and was it always your
intention to tell both stories yeah
first I just want to say thank you to
you in the academy for doing this event
I know and talking to you and other
colleagues who sort of gone through this
before this didn't used to happen to so
to have a full house here to hear
documentary filmmakers speak is amazing
especially for us a short documentary
filmmakers who often don't get the voice
so we really appreciate everyone coming
out
to to the film so I met Matthew and Tim
this project was done in conjunction
with a group called the Fetzer Institute
which is a nonprofit that promotes
awareness of love and forgiveness around
the world and they were doing some work
with Matthew and Tim's presentation to
Museum of Tolerance that they do their
regular once a month and they kind of
brought me in to sort of do some they
want to do a film about some of the work
they were doing and they sort of
presented me with some of the work they
were doing around the world and I think
Matthew and Tim's was like the first of
like 50 that they had presented in this
book and I read it and I sort of did a
double-take and you know I had to make
sure this wasn't like a scripted you
know take they had given me a treatment
for for her film because it's the story
itself is so remarkable but then it also
seemed like there was a lot to explore
in the process of forgiveness Matthew
and Tim at that point had been back in
each other's lives for about six years
so I knew there was something there that
we could dig deeper and really explore
what they had been through and what was
involved in all that you know I the
biggest challenge was building a trust
with them we I had the initial access to
them but they um their story had been
out there for about six years and when
the story first broke about them coming
back into each other's lives there was
actually a bit of a media spotlight and
they did a lot of news type stuff news
magazine type shows came in and most of
those tended to sensationalize the
attack a little bit which I don't
necessarily fault people for doing
because it's a very sensational story
but I think some of it left a bad taste
in their mouth so when I came in and
said I want to come in and make a film
about you guys but I really want to tell
the whole story I think they were sort
of like yeah yeah yeah we've heard this
before so after you know I took a little
bit of time but I think they slowly
started to realize I was kind of going a
little deeper making an extra effort to
get the whole story and to really
examine this process of forgiveness that
they had been going through at that
point for six years and you know still
even though they're in a good place
there are still things that come up and
they still struggle with certain things
even today it's really film that yet a
story that you had to reconstruct until
in retrospect what were some of the
challenges involved in that yeah so you
know we decided to tell the story we
sort of knew we were making a short and
we wanted to tell it from both of their
point of view we felt like it was
equally their story you know they both
were struggling through this process and
I think most of us when we hear about
forgiveness we automatically think of
the victim forgiving the perpetrator I
think that's that's normal when you
think of forgiveness but we wanted to
explore what Tim the perpetrator was
going through because he was going
through just as much or more than
Matthew the victim with guilt and doubt
and shame for for the life that he had
led so when Tom Christopher my co Peter
was an editor and I started put together
we really felt like we wanted to be a
balance between the two of them because
it's a balance the whole process was a
balance and and what they went through
was a balance so we tried to tell it
from both perspectives almost evenly and
sort of employed this technique where
we're sort of going back and forth
between them to tell the story karamja
has no walls incredible film images that
I will always remember you really just
take us right inside the uprising in
Yemen can you tell us how how the
project came to be the film came about
really unexpectedly and you know it was
it took us a while to bring the material
together it really it wasn't it wasn't
supposed to be a film it was supposed to
be something that we would eventually
maybe upload on to YouTube that was as
far as you know our ambitions when it's
you know at that point so my at that
point in 2011 early 2011 I was in Yemen
I was a student the film students I've
taken my camera and went back to Yemen
in order to film whatever I could those
thinking about filming my family I was
thinking about filming some some of the
protests and during that periods you
know I came across people who really
inspired me
square especially young people who were
were incredible incredibly brave and and
you know this sort of the when this
massacre happened on the 18th of March
2011 it was something that really
touched me on a very personal level
because I was connected to the square I
was connected to the people who were
involved so it was important as well you
know I really wanted to try and
encapsulate what happens in a film or in
a video that we could transmit to the to
the Yemeni masses because people really
didn't know what was happening the there
was a media blackout nothing on the
media was talking about it it kind of it
was you know as talked about in Al
Jazeera television briefly and then it
was it was gone and it was a massacre
that really shook Yemenis to the core
because you had peaceful protesters who
weren't armed and then you know there
were and they faced bullets with bare
chests and you know they really fought
to the death
basically for their dignity so
eventually I came across the footage
just snippets of the footage on online
and Nasser and yeah the footage that
they had films but but other people were
claiming that they it was their footage
so it took a while to actually locate
them to find them I got together with
with with two great guys who are in the
audience right now who who helped with
that's the process of bringing
everything together we eventually found
located the two cameramen and speaking
to them having watched the material just
snippets of it and then went deeper in
lips and some more of the material I was
I was flabbergasted because one of them
was 16 and the other one was 23 and they
had filmed incredible stuff and they
they didn't flinch in the face of
bullets and you know people dying around
them and the you know in just in order
to transmit this message to the world
you know so that gave us a bigger sense
of responsibility that we need to get
this message out there then what
happened was that i coincidentally came
across some of the family members some
of the relatives and that touched me
even more because it suddenly you know
you I think all of us maybe struggle
with this if we watched you know stuff
there's
is quite a you know violence especially
if you watch it a lot on TV then we
tempted to disconnect and detach
ourselves and desensitized so this
automatically made a real thing again
and and just watching those what was
going on through the experience of the
cameraman and through the experience
then of the the families who lost loved
ones just made it even more alive and
even more pertinent and important so
then we gathered the footage and we put
it together and and it became what it
became as the film is show yeah we
showed it a couple of times last week
whether that was one of the first times
it screens publicly and the reception
was incredible it was amazing to see
great turnout it was actually screened
funnily enough at an event hosted or
sponsored by the prime minister and a
large number of ministers also attended
which was surprising but the you know it
was also a platform for a lot of for
activists and human rights defenders to
be there and I'm talking about the
victims and talk about the day and
question them and ask about the case and
how the investigation is going because
you know a lot of people turn to us and
say well you're filmmakers you made a
film about this Massacre you know what
have you done about the culprits what
have you doing what's happening with the
investigation it's not a responsibility
so that was a good opportunity for us to
then pass on the responsibility to those
who are supposed to be doing something
about it now film serving is that
catalyst
oh yeah I think so yeah I hope so and
it's being used as well it was used by
the Human Rights Watch it's used by
their humorous organisations and by the
Ministry of Human Rights in Yemen as
well as the body of evidence and plus
the rest of the material that we managed
to gather that would support that and
where are you based I'm based in Cairo
thank you
Nicholas and Malcolm the lady in number
six music saved my life the world's
oldest living Holocaust survivor which
you can update us on Alice how did you
find this incredible woman and why
hadn't her story been told before I was
told about Alice and I was done by a
concert pianist friend of mine in New
York to go and meet her because the lady
said she was extraordinary and I didn't
want to meet her and the reason I didn't
want to meet her was because I had made
a holocaust film a few years prior to
this period in the middle middle so I
guess supposed to call it I didn't want
to make another holocaust film I didn't
want to go down that road I didn't want
to deal with those kind of psychological
issues that I had to deal with looking
at that kind of material so I and then
after three years of denial I was
actually in London my friends that were
there you may as well just go and have a
cup of tea and I did I went and had a
cup of Earl Grey tea in Northland with
Alex Souma and it changed all our lives
I think she was she's remarkable and you
know it's 45 minutes and it totally
changed my perspective because I knew
that we weren't going to be making a
holocaust go and she's much more than
that she's much bigger than that and
she's much more unique and impressive
than I had imagined so I came back to
Montreal which is where I live and where
my crew lives and I said to my to my
guys to my friends I said we're gonna go
make a movie we're gonna do it fast
you're not gonna get paid because we
haven't got any time to raise the money
because this lady is 107 she's not gonna
last very long and we need to put her on
film
so we did and she lasted another three
years and the the great tragedy of
what's happened in the last few days I'm
sure some of you have heard the news
that she died on Sunday she was 110 she
yes pretty many unwieldly despite the
fact that she was 110 we all were
completely convinced because we we
thought she was gonna go on forever you
know she was gonna there was there was a
kind of a screening and in New York on
Saturday night how's she doing she's
great she still playing the piano she
still because that's what we thought and
actually just the preview actually two
nights prior to the Saturday night
screening she had been taken into
hospital she was feeling a little bit
wobbly she lasted three days she died on
Sunday morning Nicholas why hadn't
anyone made a film about her prior to
your film I think 40 Malcolm months is
the best I think I mean the hardest
thing when we started making this film
was that when you go out to people and
say that we're making a movie about a
really old lady hundred and seven years
old who plays the piano by the way and
she survived the Holocaust and
everyone's kind of like seen the
holocaust movie and movies and it was
very hard to explain that this wasn't
that movie I think the problem that
every documentary has is how do you get
someone in five seconds to go oh and
then 30 seconds to go oh there's
something more and I think the thing we
all we all suffer from is we have these
we know if you wait if you can hang in
two minutes right you watch the trailer
you watch our movie we know we have you
but the problem is as always in this
world there are so many things going on
and so many other things to do that that
first two minutes of someone's time just
couldn't get it and you know when the
guys came out from the shoot with the
footage that was the first time when
things started to change a little bit
because suddenly you could see this lady
and you could suddenly see the magic
that she had and I think that we all
went into the film thinking this is a
really special lady
I mean Malcolm was like raving about
well okay no we get she's great but then
after those four five days shooting we
were like this is not great this is a
spectacular lady and I think that when
you I'm sure the same everyone else I
mean everybody who's been involved in
this film it's completely changed their
life
I mean her way of looking at life which
is you always look for the good and the
fact that you know when you've lived
through what she's lived through and she
says you know I'm the only one smiling
and when you're talking to her she's
always laughing she's always smiling
she's always being inquisitive you know
you're talking about her in the present
tense right yes thank you so but that's
what the there was made so special yeah
Sunday but it's like we usually you just
thought that she was never going to go
anywhere because she was that like
almost like purity you know there was
there was nothing about other than just
his pureness there was nothing else
going on with her whatsoever
extraordinary there were also two other
remarkable women in the film her friends
who are also Holocaust survivors and I
found the statement from one of the
women so profound when she talked about
lying among the corpses and she never
for a moment imagined that she could be
one of them and really what she was
saying is that so much of survival in
that situation from her perspective was
about temperament and I found that to be
remarkable and they're all evidence of
that the three of them are all yeah
they're all they're all extraordinarily
positive and I mean they're all
performers one's a one's an actress
one's a cellist one was a pianist but
they they had this extraordinary
attitude of mind where as the other lady
said you know they had two lives they
had the life that they were given and
then they had the life that they won
back by not being gassed by the Nazis
and I guess you know I mean they could
value and cherish
and appreciate what we all have but you
know we haven't many of us most of us
haven't been through that kind of awful
crucible that that forged them and made
them so unique when you meet people like
that you you you kind of feel a little
bit ashamed for how self-indulgent and
egoistic we all are and they are quite
special that's so it's it's really a
film about how to live your life it's
about and how to develop an attitude of
mind which will help you have a better
life here the last thing I says because
she doesn't get angry anybody because
she doesn't get stressed that is I think
one of the key reasons for her longevity
and I think the big thing I got away
took away from it is that we get upset
about this most stupid things and if we
could all stop getting upset about
really stupid things that energy that we
use for that if we can keep the energy
inside us that's only gonna help keep us
happier and live longer and she was the
edgar prisoner terminal the last days of
private Jack Hall so did you bring begin
with the idea of doing a film about Jack
or the hospice or how did that come to
be well I have to go back a few years in
the mid 90s I made a short film for the
Open Society Institute out of New York
it's George Soros Foundation and it was
a short nuts and bolts film on how to
start a prison hospice it wasn't the
sexiest topic on earth but it needed to
be made and it turned out to be a short
film that we sent out as a kind of a
teaching tool to hundreds of
correctional facilities around the
country and I shot it down in Angola
Louisiana which is if anybody knows
prison history it's probably one of the
worst prisons in the country and for
them to have a progressive hospice
program that incorporated the inmates as
hospice volunteers was fairly it was
very progressive so I finished that film
and I always felt like I shortchanged
the inmates down there because I was
only down there for two weeks and as
most documentary filmmakers know you
want to be in there a lot longer than
just you know blowing and blow out so in
my heart I always thought I wanted to do
a deeper much much deeper film and and
embed myself in a prison so fast-forward
you know ten twelve years and I heard
about this small program in Iowa at the
maximum state penitentiary there and so
I went there kind of cold turkey and
said look I want to do a film about your
program it's it emulates the Angola
prison and I want to stay here for a
year can I stay in a Cell and they said
no you can't stay in the Sun but they
said you can stay across the street we
have a basement that you can just set up
shop and you can stay here as long as
you want unbeknownst to me they had used
my earlier film as a teaching tool in
their hospice program so they knew me
and they knew my work and they really
trusted me so as a filmmaker to get like
24/7 access to a maximum-security prison
was a dream come true and I was there
for well
I could leave right
I know maybe yeah maybe that's why I'm
way up so no it was it was for me it was
great I mean it was also agonizing
because it you know no matter how
beautiful the program is in a prison
it's also a very soul sucking
environment and um you know so it did
take its toll emotionally and stuff but
yeah it was it was a great opportunity
to over how long a period I was there
for six months I was gonna be they
actually let me stay there for a year
two months into my stay there was nobody
in the hospice program I was like what's
going on you know so I started filming
probably about a month into my stay and
then Jack was a long-term infirmary
patient there and he started getting
sick he got double pneumonia at one
point and it looked like he was gonna
kind of go down the tubes so I realized
yeah I'm just gonna follow Jack so I
talked to Jack and I said look I'm when
I'm doing this film about the hospice
program here in the prison and if I can
follow you to your dying breath is that
possible Jack and he's at shirt or
whatever you want you know it's which
was great because he was his family was
very open and and he knew that he was
gonna leave a legacy really for other
prisons and prisoners to look at this
film and maybe think that this program
can be emulated without a problem you
know across the country so it was very
he was very giving in that sense I want
to ask you each to say why short form
was the right form for your story and
were you ever tempted to cross the line
into future was it evident from the
get-go that you were really working in
in short form in my case it was not I
had as a matter of fact in my case I
wasn't even sure when I was finished
filming but it did reach a point where I
thought I was doubling back on material
I already had before and I took all that
material into the Edit Bay my editor
Aaron Nordstrom is out there in the
audience somewhere and we put on we put
a structure on the wall and we said it's
gonna land at whatever length it
naturally wants to be we didn't know
what that was the first cut was probably
40
seven minutes and then we ended up
cutting about nine minutes out of it
yeah we we started went in with the idea
that we were gonna make us short we did
entertain doing something longer but
when my editor Tom Christopher who's
here as well in the audience when we
sort of what I said earlier when we
start to put the film together we
realized the the the whole process of
forgiveness itself was such a
individualistic journey that we felt
like we just wanted the two of them
telling their story and so other voices
were maybe gonna interfere with that and
with two voices Matthew my subject is
here tonight as well and this is no
offense to Matthew but sorry you could
apply for him back but to have two
voices for 60 minutes would not work
with anyone I mean maybe it could work
but so we sort of just felt like I think
we knew we were gonna go over like 30
with the two of them telling this story
as the two voices and we we felt like we
had a nice arc to the story and it was
working so we stuck with that well
apartment initially being a you know
five minute YouTube video once it then
you know you know it came to our
realization that it was actually going
to become a film we we filmed a number
of of characters apart from the four
that are actually in the film or five if
you can include the young boy we had to
think ten characters and footage from
the angles of six different cameramen
and and then I realized during the Edit
that it meant that I had to really go
into depth you know and so what happened
on the day but also in the M&E
revolution because you're now sort of in
a position where you have to answer
questions about one where where Yemen is
on the map which is you know so and then
going into the details of the
government's and why people wanted to
revolt and if you have that much time to
spend and if
and you might as well you know bring
those details in but then I found that
it was because Yemen is there was so it
the the the revolution as you know it is
in Egypt and and and the other Arab
Spring country is very convoluted and it
you know and and things were also
changing very quickly so there was no
way I could keep up and and put across a
message or the story which is really
up-to-date so really focusing on one day
and just focusing on the humanity and on
the human suffering but also on the
perseverance and the braveness made me
then cut it down from the the the what I
thought was the final cuts initially was
47 minutes and then I brought it down to
26 minutes and I felt that I could get
so much more of the emotion into the 26
minutes by focusing on two fathers and
two cameraman and keeping it simple but
within context and then maybe then
through the film people would want to
explore what what happened in Yemen
during its revolution I don't think we
made a short I think we made a long
because I thought this film was gonna be
about five minutes long I honestly I
mean all joking aside I didn't think
there was any hope in hell of making a
film as long as we did we didn't set out
to make a way I thought we make in 10-15
minutes that's what I thought these
little bond more these little wonderful
gems that Alice came out with and then
call freed who's here my editor and no
no we genuinely didn't think we were we
were going to be making a film this one
interestingly when I met her that first
time and I thought clearly she was great
she was a great subject for a film but I
didn't know all the other stuff I didn't
know about Kafka I don't know Marla I
didn't know about you know a lot of the
details of the
the camp it was just this kind of
extraordinarily unique positive
uncynical unalloyed optimism that
captivated me so when we found out all
this other stuff which we only actually
found out when we went to shoot we had a
bigger movie than we thought
and what's interesting about any film
and I know everyone in on this stage is
gonna do this is something we can all
agree on every scene in every film has a
right length has lots and lots of wrong
lengths but there's an integrity to
every scene and if you hit the sweet
spot in any scene you what you were
saying about your film it's it worked
better at 26 minutes because somehow it
everything kind of came together with
our film it was really that we had no
idea where we were gonna land with 27 we
weren't thinking oh you know if we make
this 27 minutes we'll be able to sell it
to television the producer we we could
have made it 52 minutes and it would
have been a terrible movie because it
was it would have been too long so we
had to hit the sweet spot the sweet spot
happened to come in around 38 minutes
pure accident um I actually set out to
make a feature I shot thank you I will
say it
no because I thought I mean I still
think the subject merits a feature but
the truth is I shot for six months and
it wasn't like I kept the camera on and
walked away I mean I shot three three
hundred hours of footage of really
fantastic stuff I'll say myself and I
thought I'm gonna but I also shot it and
I also loved everything I shot which is
dangerous when you're not when you're
editing because I was have I was making
a miniseries it was like and so I was I
was like wait this is getting huge I
don't handle so I actually now in
retrospect the fact that the film is 39
minutes long I mean I think because of
the subject matter and it's it's a tough
it's a tough one I think it's a perfect
length because I think we hit all the
other issues that I wanted to hit in the
film
also I think there's an emotional cord
that runs through the whole thing that
if it were any longer I think people
would just be devastated a little bit
more than they are now maybe but um yeah
I think it's a perfect length I'm really
happy and you know trust me I I know we
have I have a lot of great scenes and
which will be online later this year